I have some exciting news.
(gasps) Oh, this is very exciting.
I'm really excited.
Okay, so I'm gonna be sitting
at another news desk this week.
(gasps) Say what?
Yes.
This Monday and Tuesday, I'm joining the CBS
this morning with Gayle King and Anthony Mason
while Tony Dokoupil is gonna be out
because he's having a baby.
Drew, this is huge!
I know!
I keep telling my girls, I'm just like,
this is such a dream of mine.
I love the news so much and I just can't believe
I found myself at this time in life.
I can't believe it.
I can't wait to see you next to Gayle King.
I'm gonna be watching live, Drew.
Like texting you during the show.
I was gonna say, I'll be asking your opinion
the whole way through, Rossy,
because you are the best partner in news crime
a girl could ever ask for.
Thank you.
I'll just, I'll be watching,
I'll be outside the window waving.
Hi! Hi, Drew. (laughs)
All right. Well, let's kick off our news today
by looking back in a new segment we're calling
"This Day in Pop Culture History".
(whirring sounds)
That's right.
(Ross laughs)
(imitates whirring sound) Um, okay.
Check this out.
On this day, in 1977, a young radio hopeful
took the airwaves for the very first time
on WRNW
in Briarcliff Manor, New York.
Who was it?
Just a little fella named Howard Stern.
Howard was 23 years old and his first shift
was a mid-day slot with a take-home pay of 96 bucks a week.
He now reportedly makes 1.9 million a week.
Here's a quick listen to Howard back in 1977.
Hi, I'm Howard Stern,
the program director of Westchester's rock station.
You know, it's really hard to describe
what makes a radio station a success.
We hear WRNW have narrowed it down
to a very few special elements.
First and foremost, the music.
I mean..
It's so weird to hear.
I don't know how he looks older then than he does now.
(Ross laughs)
But listen, we all know where that went.
He changed the world.
He's the king of all media and he grew his signature persona
and his full body take no prisoners interviewing style.
And he became the most fined radio host in FCC history.
After a 44-year career, he's still going strong.
And I remember the first time that I was interviewed by him.
I've interviewed people for 20 years now.
And I thought to myself after he interviewed me,
I thought I'm such a better interviewer
because of what I just sat there and saw him do.
He's so well-researched
and yet he leads it as a disarming conversation.
There is no one better in the business than Howard Stern.
And who knew a shock jock who made 96 bucks a week
would become the interview of a lifetime.
If you are lucky enough to be in his hot seat,
well, you're very lucky and I...
Hats off to Howard Stern.
The best of the best, Howard.
All right, next.
Don't never say never, ever, ever, ever, ever.
'Cause sometimes exes do get back together.
The Independent says rumors are swirling.
Have you seen this?
It's everywhere.
Jennifer Lopez, yeah,
and Ben Affleck are rekindling the romance after 17 years.
Remember, they were Bennifer.
Oh, it changed everything.
We now put everybody's name in a mashup because of Bennifer.
Well, yeah, they were the first
and now, they're Bennifer 2.0, people are thinking.
Therapists say though,
"Is this a good idea to get back with your ex?"
They say before you get back together,
you should examine why you broke up in the first place.
And try this.
Imagine that you never met your ex before.
And if you met them now as strangers,
would you be totally attracted?
Because it's like, are you just thinking about
how good it was at one point, the romance of that?
Hmm, have you ever gotten back with an ex?
Ah. Oh, my God.
Around the bend, many times.
(Ross laughs)
If I dated 17 years ago, a guy,
I am so not the same person.
My issues back then would not be my issues now.
And so, I think about myself in that context
and I have to give it up to people
because I've changed so much.
Interesting. Hm, you really changed my mind, Drew.
Hm, interesting.
Well, luckily we never have to break up, Rossy.
(Ross laughs)
We can just stay together.
(upbeat music)